Hey,
we've put on
eh 1 obligation to ourselves.
You are also this campaign
and is to raise the level of political debate
and the political essay that I have made public is
you intend to make a contribution in this regard.
Do we believe that there is 1 policy that is exhausted?
and it is conventional policy
and and conventional politics
what you do when 1 election campaign is approaching?
So is it throwing outbursts
eh?
Make 1 mud policy,
Making promises that have not been kept
in recent years,
when you have had responsibilities
and institutional
in order to execute these promises
or even the listening process.
Each time 1 election campaign approaches
1 listening process is activated.
I think we know enough.
We already had time to listen eh?
And that
it is time to make 1 diagnosis
of how this country is doing,
because we live 1 special historical moment
big changes are taking place,
we face immeasurable challenges as follows
eh years and we have to do 1 exercise.
I believe that in the coming weeks
can be 1 favorable time to establish
1 public conversation
around
to how this country is doing in this historic moment,
what are the challenges you face and how do you
it is necessary to face,
what policy we need to meet the challenges
of country and uh,
well,
the political essay I have written
is 1 contribution to meaning.
I took 1 step eh?
Up front,
let's get this political essay across
to the Rest of the candidates
and I would like to.
it's 1 invitation to the rest of the candidates.
and the political essay